el siguiente ejercicio será hacer la
resta correspondiente a 5 puntos 73
menos 0.08 21 cuánto será esto lo
primero que ocupamos hacer y ustedes lo
han hecho una y otra vez es que acomode
hemos dado que son decimales
estos números de acuerdo a la ubicación
del punto y veamos tendremos entonces
cinco puntos 73 menos este punto va
perfectamente alineado con el de arriba
por lo que tendremos en las unidades un
0 y en los decimales 082 1
ya lo hemos visto en otros ejercicios y
lo que solemos hacer es rellenar estos
espacios hacia la derecha después del
punto decimal con ceros y con ello
tenemos bloques perfectamente
completos para poder hacer nuestras
restas el cero es más pequeño que el 1
por lo que vamos a ocupar pedir prestado
de las columnas de al lado podemos
pedirle al cero no pero si podemos
pedirle al 30 tomaremos este 30 completo
y le pediremos 1 por lo que se
convertirá en 29
y aquí tendremos un 10 ahora el 10 es
más grande que el 1 podemos hacer
nuestra resta el 9 es más grande que el
2 porque podremos hacer nuestra resta
pero aquí este 2 no nos funcionará así
es que volveremos a hacer una solicitud
de préstamo y este 7 se convertirá en 6
mientras que este 2 se convertirá en 12
vamos claros ahora el 6 sin duda es más
grande que el 0 y el 5 es de igual
manera más grande que el 0 hagamos
entonces nuestra resta cuánto es 10
menos uno es igual a 99 menos 2 es igual
a 7
12 - 8 es igual a 4
es decir tenemos cuatro espacios entre
el 8 y el 12
60 es igual a 6 y bajemos nuestro punto
decimal nunca lo olvidemos
5 - 0 es igual a 5 por lo que nuestro
número final indica que 5.73 menos 0.08
21 es igual a 5.6 479 vamos bien hagamos
un ejercicio más que tal que hacemos
espacio cuánto será ahora 8.25 menos
0.01 0.5
ustedes ya lo pueden hacer solo sé que
si les pregunto cuál será nuestro primer
paso ustedes ya no tienen muy consciente
y efectivamente nuestro primer paso será
alinear los números de acuerdo al punto
decimal empecemos tenemos entonces 8.25
y bajamos este punto perfectamente
alineado tenemos cero puntos 0 10 5
esto es una resta y haremos el ejercicio
vamos a rellenar estos dos espacios con
los ceros para que tengamos columnas
completas estamos de acuerdo y ahora
haremos la revisión de si ocupamos pedir
prestado el cero es más pequeño que el 5
por lo que si ocuparemos pedir prestado
sin embargo no podemos pedírselo al de
al lado nos vamos hasta el siguiente y a
50 sin duda podemos pedirle entonces
este 50 se convierte en 4 y en 9
y aquí tendremos un 10 el 10 ya es más
grande que el 5 el 9 es más grande que
el 0 el 4 es más grande que el 1 el 2 es
más grande que el 0 e igual el 8 es más
grande que el 0 por lo que podremos
hacer ahora nuestra respectiva resta
bajemos del punto decimal para que jamás
lo olvidemos
y ahora tenemos que 10 5 es igual a 5 90
es igual a 94 menos 1 es igual a 3 y 20
es igual a 280 es igual a 8 por lo que
8.25 menos 0.01 0.5 es igual a 8 punto
23 95 se dan cuenta como esto cada vez
se vuelve muchísimo más sencillo vamos a
hacer uno más cuánto será ahora 2.64
menos 0.04 8
hoy creo que mi 8 me quedo medio feo
ahí está mucho más bonito esto será
igual a cuanto ok volvamos a hacer lo
que ustedes ya saben alineamos puntos
decimales
tenemos 2.64 y bajamos el punto y
tenemos un 0 a las unidades 0 4 8 6
esto lo restaremos y ahora rellenaremos
exactamente rellenaremos para que las
columnas se queden perfectamente
completas
hagamos la revisión si pediremos
prestado o no pero es más pequeño que el
6 por lo que si si pediremos entonces
este no podemos pedirle a la columna de
la izquierda por lo que nos recorreremos
uno más y sin duda el 40 así podemos
pedirle entonces este 40 se vuelve 39
y este se volverá un 10/10 ya es más
grande que el 69 es más grande que el 8
sin embargo este 3 es más pequeño que el
4 por lo que le pediremos a la columna
de al lado y este se convertirá en un 5
mientras que este se convertirá en 13 13
ahora ya es más grande que el 45 es más
grande que el 0 y el 2 es más grande que
el 0 vamos a hacer ahora nuestras
respectivas restas y tenemos que 10
menos 6 es igual a 49 menos 8 es igual a
13 recuerdan que este es el que nos
prestaron 13 menos 4 es igual a 9 y 5 -0
es igual a 5
ponemos nuestro punto decimal y 20 es
igual a 2 por lo que 2 puntos 64 menos
0.04 806 es igual a 2.59 14
ven como esto es mucho más sencillo
realmente ya tenemos las bases de las
restas con grandes números y ahora solo
ocupamos tener perfecto control del
punto decimal jamás perderlo para que
así podamos hacer nuestros ejercicios de
la manera adecuada con calma practiquen
y practiquen y practiquen y esto nos
llevará a tener siempre resultados
adecuados nos estamos viendo en el
siguiente vídeo ok